you are in this segment of the room
would you like a wrap
v-necks yeah would you clarify what
you're wearing a v-neck
this is a plunge yes it is madam it
really is
i knew that's not a v-neck i just wanted
an excuse to carry on a conversation
with you um
it is a plunge v-necks thank you um
people
here what would you like to wrap about
so you said kinky historical figures or
figure figures figures do you have any
in mind
it's probably the popes isn't it it's
the post
pope innocent ain't no innocent um
so kinky historical figures
catherine the great yeah i guess she was
yeah if you don't know why you'll find
out why in the wrap okay catherine the
great king historical figures v-necks
let's come to people over here watch
like a rapper
the oxford comma brilliant thank you
very much those who don't know it's the
comma you put after
well before an end at the end of the
list
um great
uh this you can tell you're a sunday
crowd it's really lovely
history and grammar please
but also some titties also titties
[Applause]
people over here what would you like a
rapper
trafalgar square thank you for putting
on that accent as well um trafalgar
square um cool trafalgar square if you
don't know it's in in london outside the
national gallery where we have lots of
cool paintings that i'm not entirely
sure if we're allowed to own but we do
trafalgar square v-necks king historical
figures and uh
what would you want to go
catholic
oh come on how can i forget um it's
funny that that was at the end of a list
as well
and then one final one doesn't come from
anywhere else
so somehow well because we've said top
boy we can't that's the name of the
estate in top boy it's too much top boy
based trivia in the show in the show for
a show that no one has watched um i know
drake loves it that's why it exists but
anyway so for one final one
[Music]
there were so many what did you say
ivan the terrible okay cool weird
because he's not genghis khan and he's
not vlad the impaler he's like the kind
of third
ranking person you don't have to all be
history you know it's not like did he
see if he really went to oxford i did
but i studied archaeology and that's not
i thought it would be just like indiana
jones but like you don't get a small
chinese boy
and what did you say from over here
someone said something from here
okay cool yeah
is that arriving the terrible i try to
remember one of them
so to remind you we have v-necks we have
the oxford comma we have historical
figures who are kinky cashman or great
is one of them not summer house maybe
it's not in titties snit yes no in
cocaine or cities
yeah yes i know
it's late it's been a long week
i've been the terrible and the other one
we had was
no it wasn't travaga square it wasn't
crumpets but thank you um
there's too many words but we'll try it
this is a freestyle that's alright made
up on the spot base and telling their
suggestions oh my gosh there's an
incredible band here would you play some
music for me please my friends it would
be so nice thank you so much
i'm very excited to hear what this is
because the other night red was
surprised he didn't realize i was here
so he didn't have a song prepared but
now he's going to make up a song
oh
oh it's some little kalimba steel drums
what is this this is fun look at you
with your magic fingers and a little
tambourine as well
kick you off words coming from my mouth
apologies to man here saying wrap out
the summer house that's an east london
estate asha d it's a top boy reference i
give him for free i'll be going to hot
topic maybe have a grumpy and fitch i
wanna get another scoop net that fits
want a brand new one that exposes my
sternum that's your little chest bone
yeah i prefer them the v-necks i inspect
make them so deep got some heavy
sunglasses on all the ladies weep when
they see it they're like chest is
basically bear feel self-conscious why
cause i've no chest hair but it's fine
though
marco he'd be italian all the follicles
coming out you'd be telling some v-necks
looking so pretty it's nice technically
this is a plunge but maybe those titties
can get some cocaine on that's a fat
line i can get my nose down there have a
mad time snorting all of these even
though i usually don't do cocaine but
maybe for you i won't well that's a
double negative that's a grammatical
mistake if you want to get an education
and take they're like you gotta make
sure when you start a list you like name
name and then don't miss the little dash
there it's like an apostrophe that's run
out of helium and slowly moves down to
the line that's a nice little image let
me talk about a guy who loved to pillage
and probably rape and do other bad
things yo ivan the terrible
roaming around causing such harm there's
no cause for alarm cause he's not
genghis khan so he ain't spreading all
his dna probably from russia but back in
the day when they weren't being
genocidal maniacs invading ukraine and
then we got some more yeah straight from
the brain whoa get the cheers it's easy
to do i'm over in london what am i gonna
do truly i love art with all my heart
i'm looking on the map of the tube where
i start and then i travel here i'm like
are all of you aware i'm a tour guide
now in trafalgar square holding up a
little umbrella maybe a broly and what's
this oh well you'll be sorry that i
explained this i'm going to tell some
this is a column and on the top of it
nelson nelson's column he beat people in
the navel battle trafalgar square well i
could even tattle i could tell there's
the fourth plinth from the start they
change it every quarter of the year and
put a new work of art if you've been
tripped for falgor you'll know this is
true but the last one we're coming to
you put a real finger to your chin
acting all kind of stinky make it
historical figure this kinky i'm like oh
this is gonna be fun mate she loves
sucking horse dick catherine the great
[Applause]